[Music]
in press for sex news control-alt-delete
yeah
you maybe belly dance surviving dancing
is sexy when ladies do po and guys do it
it's not sexy it's sexy one guys with a
thousand things in that category
okay submitted by taste the rainbow my
opening my mouth is seeing on my tongue
fine taste the rainbow means sucker
leprechauns dick I thought was just
spills I thought I was taking her tongue
in a butthole I really just thought it
was skittles to you knows the inventor
of the sex button responds to going
viral and receiving hate backlash what
sex button so then I'll just show you
their Kickstarter video okay and I like
this I can't like the boy this is only
here we go I love her I love him I'm
just not always sure she's ready to do
some dancing sheets when I am cuz you're
crazy as [ __ ]
[Music]
eventually it leads us to stop trying as
often hmm well you're in luck because
there's love sing love sync is a device
that lets you know and both of you are
in the mood for some hippity-dippity oh
my god alliance these anonymous inputs
and recognizes that there is consensus
it lets you both know by emitting a
swirling glow from the buttons where's
the end of that wire they were sitting
next to each other and they couldn't
just say what's the difference between
actually communicating in averages the
button pheromones oh they press it what
I thought was oh and that's dumb I think
it'd be cool if it didn't have a wire
and then like if he's at work I'm at
work than like you can communicate like
hey thinking about you but then also you
could detect - absolutely they like apps
are controlled like dildos and you can
do that from work at home
I thought it was gonna be more advanced
yeah like it smelt like my pheromone it
told me I want to do is is it avoids it
avoids rejection on both parts because
what it does is I like it'll sync only
when both agree yeah so you could send
that and then if it does if nothing
sends back and you just know I person
them and they don't know that you asked
if you're not I can see I can see you're
not there like it could be like you
started the day in the morning like I
want to [ __ ] today and then and then
maybe like later on in the afternoon
yeah she's like oh I want to [ __ ] today
too but she doesn't know that you're you
want to isn't that kind of rejection
though I got till you press it ain't
nothing they're just like okay
so they suppress it everyday she doesn't
have to say to you for the 1000th time
yeah no no no honey I don't feel like it
you just you just look at it in this
blank and you're like I mean she spills
or indirectly tells I get it I'm
rejected they can't see your manners and
there it is there it is so what's the
big deal right now you're where they can
hate Friday because it's stupid oh
really oh because everyone's like why
can't you just tell them you're horny
but then so the couple that created this
they are from Ohio named Ryan and Jen it
looks like this they've been married for
15 years and they say like you know
they're not prudes but they're not like
you know everyone struggles with
communication sometimes especially when
it comes to sex and so they thought that
this would be something that could help
a lot of couples to increase the amount
of times that they'd be having sex and
sometimes they don't know when they're
horny or you know whatever so they're
saying they're trying to enhance the
romance increase sexual frequency avoid
awkward rejection and improve romantic
communication by using this but I mean
they're really close to their goal
anyways so it's actually not a pastor
goal so we pledged 7,500 on Kickstarter
and out right now they're at ten
thousand six hundred a lot of people
they like get anyone uh so the money so
so people are like this is so stupid
but let me pledge anyway because I need
it I just but I'm just saying people are
epic rates that way whether you can talk
about your [ __ ] but they're like ah this
is dumb yeah especially people that
don't want to be so open with their
sexuality that's exactly
I kind of see that's why I thought I
thought this was cool because you know
not everyone talks about everybody a lot
of people so sex is a hard conversation
to have for a lot of people especially
when you didn't grow up in a household
where you it was it's okay to talk about
sex also a different generation because
they're in their forties
they're just like you know it's not they
might be experiencing a set of problems
that we don't even understand or know
yeah they might be from
super-conservative households to where
like you know they still want to make
kids and have sex but then they want to
they don't want to be rejected and they
want to you know like it's third they
live so many different or reject yeah or
fuel yeah yeah like having to tell them
all the time no no no no like that's you
know what some crazy-ass [ __ ] that
happened so like my parents are divorced
right since I was six
and then in when I was 14 15 I got into
a bunch of trouble in school so my dad's
idea was like he's gonna move back in
and then so that way there's someone
watching me at night and during the day
as my dad works graveyard shift and so
he comes in and he comes in and this is
the but for one quarter in my entire
high school career I got the best grades
I her for that because my dad was there
and I got a three point three and he
would pay me like four A's and B's and
stuff like that and I was oh [ __ ] I'll
have to sell weed to make money I can't
do my homework and so I actually got the
best grades possible but the whole time
my mom's eating her vegetarian [ __ ]
my dad's eating his meat [ __ ]
they're not really talking my dad still
smoking a carton of cigarettes a day by
himself so I to me it was like they
they're both there for me they're super
divorced one day I go into my mom's
bedroom because I need to ask her
something and then I thought she was
sleeping on the way it's kind of early
to be sleeping
I opened the sheet my mom's [ __ ]
titties and my dad flea right next to my
mom and I'm like I thought you guys hate
each other still and you guys turn up
sleeping
what's she hiding cuz I was it was in
the dark so it's not I would even be
like I wouldn't even suspect like 14
like I wouldn't even suspect that my dad
would be there so maybe if I had a third
button
[ __ ] right now Oh garlic crazy boy the
thing you have to know about his mom is
she's super innocent little communicate
so I can I can I can understand like two
forty year olds that dog cuz I really
thought they hated each other what she's
super innocent and she I mean she didn't
even have like like boyfriends and [ __ ]
you know like guys come over when he was
growing up so yeah like it wouldn't it's
not weird for him to open up her sheets
cuz you know what I mean like she's just
like a very like sweet innocent and my
mom always sleeps with like one of those
like robes you know so it's just normal
hey mom like hey I'm late for school are
they going to talk through in that way
but yeah I think they're trying to get
it on and I think I [ __ ] block my dad
what did you do when you caught them no
I just if I freaked out I ran to the
bathroom I just closed to dry locked in
aw [ __ ] yeah that's the safest place
Tamela did they talk to you after yeah
my mom and my dad are they trying to
knock on the door like hey we couldn't
explain and I'm like oh you like like I
don't need an explanation I know what
that happened just freak me out you
thought they were about to they probably
[ __ ] many times before that is what
I'm thinking
Shelagh that this Japanese excuse was
let's do it for him yeah let's do it for
fit but that deep down inside of like
damn I missed that dick and they're like
yeah yeah for the for the kid we got to
do this yeah for the kid yeah
hate cuts though cuz we still never let
me do he lives with me for a good six
months and we never had a family dinner
like mom and dad style it would be like
either I'm eating with my mom because
she hates his guts or I'm eating with my
dad cause he hates her guts so I just
was not just caught me off guard like a
mother and they had some hate sex yeah I
just can't even picture them having hate
sex like that that's crazy
didn't they stay in the same house for
your wedding no [ __ ] yeah your aunt
was there what has happened you know
anything is possible it's so funny to
cuz the way your mom looks at your dad
is with so much disguise it was the same
disgust like my dad would be cooking his
[ __ ] steaks yeah she's just I am like
you [ __ ] like you [ __ ] meat-eating
piece of [ __ ] that are [ __ ] so weird
but yeah I mean they got funded on their
Kickstarter for this love sink invention
thing here make that money yeah I mean
whatever helps people in their love life
and especially in their sex life I mean
hey I do think it's weird that they
can't just be yeah opening but at the
same time I do see how this will help
people yeah and the best inventions
often start as a niche or start as if
they are true inventors and they did it
for their own cause like oh we really
need this there is someone else out
there yeah and even if it's a small
percentage I do think it's cool I do
think it's weird there's there's
different levels to open this right like
people probably [ __ ] with the sheets on
like I didn't have a sex like sexy yeah
there's a hole in the sheet so modest
you know well I bet you their sex sheet
has like a big face of like Jesus or
something and in his nose is like you
have to stick a stick dick inside
through there and
no Jesus in there because it because you
have to remember like this this is the
same it's holy like they're not doing it
for like pleasures doesn't feel good
this doesn't feel good yeah we're
listening to the radio this morning and
they're doing like the survey thing and
then there's couples that aren't even
comfortable of using the bathroom while
the other ones in the shower yet for
sure so that [ __ ] blew my mind cuz to me
that's like that's TV Nicki yeah that's
so much separate bathroom so I think if
you're already that distant they're not
distant in the relationship sexually or
not but if there's that distant in
different ways I can totally see maybe
people like that need that too yeah cuz
they're just like so distant ones are
like okay I know there's so many
eggshells around certain topics I can't
really talk about certain people and
it's like if you could just press a
button like he's doing [ __ ] you're so
far thrown after poop press a button for
what I have to [ __ ] yeah
[Music]